NARRATOR: It's the season
finale of Live Free or Die.
Five people
living in the wild...
TONY: Boom shaka-laka!
NARRATOR: Have
shown us their lives.
COLBERT: Ever since I
was a little kid I've been
dreaming about
living in the woods.
NARRATOR:
They've been tested.
THORN: It's been
two degrees at night.
GABRIEL: In California
we're in a severe drought.
Everything seems to
be dead out here.
NARRATOR: But their
will hasn't faltered.
AMELIA: Swarm!
TONY: Ah... I'm getting stung.
NARRATOR: They've proven...
THORN: There's
no failure here.
NARRATOR: Just
how far they can go.
GABRIEL: It's a big
deal to take a life.
Uh...there's the arrow.
COLBERT: I actually
built this house...every
screw...every nail
and now it's gone.
[Thorn screams].
NARRATOR: Now
they're fight continues.
GABRIEL: I don't
have too many choices;
I've got to
catch a couple fish.
THORN: My little girl
Briar is just so sick.
[Briar coughing].
I've got to get
some medicine.
COLBERT: I'm rebuilding
my home with my family.
NARRATOR: Because their
quest to live free never ends.
TONY: This is the way
that we want to live.
It'll be that way
until the day I die.
NARRATOR: There is a
movement growing in America.
These pioneers
have made a choice...
To awaken the animal self
by going back to the wild.
GABRIEL: It's
windier than I thought.
Alright...I'm
gonna try my luck.
NARRATOR: In
California...nomadic hunter
Gabriel is about to
begin the final leg of his
grueling journey.
Having trekked nearly 40
miles from the mountain
cabin where he spent the
past several months...
Gabriel is now
headed down the coast...
home to his fiancé Luna.
GABRIEL: This has been
an awesome experience out
on the land.
But at the same time
I'm engaged to Luna.
We've been
together ten years.
It's time for us to start
the next chapter together.
A lot of the times we
go out on journeys...
I'm hunting or fishing or
gathering some kind of food
source to bring home for
Luna and for both of us and
so I usually don't like
to come home empty-handed.
NARRATOR: Gabriel will
try his luck using a simple
improvised hand line.
GABRIEL: I've got my yucca
with a good hook on the end.
I'm gonna go get some
mussels out before the tide
comes in too much.
NARRATOR: But heavy
ocean currents will make it
challenging to
keep the line steady.
GABRIEL: It's crazy
out here right now.
It's like full storm surge.
It's a hard time to
be out in the water.
It's kind of dangerous
'cause there's rip tides and
waves moving everywhere.
Alright that should be good.
Let's get out there.
So basically I'm gonna head
out here and tie myself into
the kelp and try to drop my
hand line down into the kelp
bed all the way
to the bottom.
I have to be careful of
the waves...the current...
the wind and
also the sharks.
The ocean kills
people really easy.
It's a place where if you
don't know how to move and
bend with the currents
then it'll take you under.
It's not the best time to be
fishing in the kelp bed but
I don't have
too many choices.
I gotta catch a couple fish.
NARRATOR: With escalating
gale force winds and choppy
heaving swells Gabriel's
quest for a fish is risky.
GABRIEL: It's pretty
crazy lumpy right now.
There's a big riptide.
Ohhh!
NARRATOR: While Gabriel
struggles against the
ocean's currents...
in North Carolina...
homesteaders Tony and
Amelia are testing out a
new way to feed
their chickens.
AMELIA: They're
gonna love this...
c'mon chickens.
TONY: C'mon boogies.
AMELIA: Woooo...oh my God!
We've got thousands
and thousands of maggots
in this bucket.
They're eating what
was once a ground hog...
has basically
turned into nothing.
Flies have flown in
through the top holes...
they've laid eggs on the
roadkill and the eggs...
which are turning
into maggots...
are falling out
of the bottom.
TONY: It's raining maggots.
AMELIA: Alright
chickens...go for it.
TONY: There they go.
AMELIA: These maggots
are extremely nutritious
for the chickens.
They give them
plenty of protein.
TONY: Maggot showers
equals happy chickens.
Happy chickens
equals delicious eggs.
NARRATOR: Tony and Amelia
have dedicated their lives
to being entirely
self-sufficient.
But finding a way to
eat only what they grow
has been a challenge.
TONY: Three years
we've been here.
AMELIA: Yeah.
TONY: We've done pretty
good for three years of swale
digging and tree planting.
NARRATOR: Tony and Amelia
fought every possible element
to turn this
uninhabitable hill into a
fully sustainable homestead.
TONY: So you know
what we should do today?
AMELIA: What's that?
TONY: We should have a
little feasting on the
forest garden to celebrate our
three-year land anniversary.
We've got plenty of
vegetables to eat.
AMELIA: Yeah.
TONY: Let's do it.
NARRATOR: Before
the harvest begins...
Tony's gonna make use of
something else from the garden.
TONY: So it's Amelia and I's
three-year anniversary of
living on the land together
and I'm wanting to make
Amelia something really cool
for an anniversary present.
We're dealing with
some foul (bleep) here.
This pig came from our
neighbor's pig that we
helped slaughter.
It's pretty "F'ing" gross.
I saw the teeth
and I was like...
"God those teeth
are really cool."
So I could make a really
cool you know cavewoman
necklace for Amelia.
I think Amelia will be
stoked that I had the nerve
to pull these teeth out
and touch this greasy...
stinky pig remnants.
I'm a little nervous
that I'm going to vomit.
Yeah...hell no.
AMELIA: Are you gonna vomit?
TONY: I'm alright.
Yeah...ugh...ugh!
Actually I'm just
not gonna do this.
No I have to.
I gotta get 'er done.
I'm gonna have to
muster up the will to touch
a rotten pig's head
to get the teeth out.
These are the things that
a person will do for love.
These aren't really budging.
I think we can come
back to these later.
NARRATOR: As Tony mulls
over pulling pig's teeth...
five and a half
miles over the ridge...
primitive woodsman
Thorn is beginning a project
of his own.
THORN: My new shelter's
looking really good.
I'm pretty proud.
It's awesome to have the
difficult things out of the
way and now I can move
onto a little bit more of
the fun stuff.
You know what I was
thinking about doing today?
I wanna build a
bunk bed with you.
I have my bed finished.
BRIAR: I thought
that was my bed!
No...I'm gonna build
you one a little higher up.
BRIAR: Don't forget you
should have shoes on.
THORN: I'm good.
BRIAR: Ok you're good.
THORN: Out here I've got
a really enormous forest to
pull resources out of
and I'm really lucky.
It's not like
buying all the lumber.
This is my lumber yard.
BRIAR: Daddy...I'm
getting so excited.
THORN: I know... I'm
excited too for you.
I might be more thrilled
than she is because it's
really hard to
sleep with her.
She just kicks me
all night long.
I don't know what she's
dreaming about but it's
gotta have something to
do with fighting a bunch
of Ninjas off.
Back where we moved
from in our house...
we had a bunk bed.
And I built it for
her it was awesome.
I knew she loved it.
NARRATOR: The A-frame
structure of Thorn's new
shelter will allow him
to frame two crossbeams
directly above
his existing bed.
BRIAR: Daddy... you're
making a mess in here!
THORN: Yeah.
[hammering].
BRIAR: Yeah it's
almost there I think.
THORN: Just
gotta make a ladder.
I'm really appreciating
having this open floor plan.
At some point in the future
I can move onto some walls
but I don't need to do
that until the fall.
That's pretty good.
Check it out.
BRIAR: I can even
stand up a little.
THORN: Yeah...
just a little?
Briar's totally into it...
she loves it.
It's not a huge bunk bed
but it's not a huge house.
I think I'm gonna
sleep better tonight too.
It's win-win.
[Briar coughing].
NARRATOR: But any plans
for today will have to be
put on hold as Briar's
nagging cough has taken a
turn for the worse.
[Briar coughing].
THORN: It's not a good one.
My little girl Briar...
she's pretty sick right now.
[Briar coughing].
You want some medicine?
I'm just about out.
I'm running low on
medicine and I really need to
attend to this cough.
NARRATOR: As Thorn cares
for his sick daughter...
in the swamp of south
Georgia frontiersman
Colbert's grandchildren have
come to help him rebuild.
COLBERT: You
remember the cabin?
They've been coming since
they were little bitty kids
and it's great to have all
four of them come at one
time to share in the fun.
NARRATOR: This is their
first visit since his cabin
burned down this winter.
COLBERT: Now this
is a super antique.
This is over 100 year-old
screwdriver and it had a
wooden handle on it.
CODY: So many
memories in that place and
now it's just gone.
COLBERT: Do you
recognize what this is?
DEVON: That
would be the .22.
We always used to sit out on
the porch and just basically
tell jokes all night.
COLBERT: Everything
in life is temporary and
everything is precious.
It's always a traumatic
experience when you lose
something that we
put a lot of value on.
To me...to help me make a
transition of letting go of
emotional attachment to
material things I guess
that's a lesson I
needed to learn.
So I've been dragging
all this new logs in to
rebuild the cabin.
So we're gonna dig a
hole to put the pole in.
I remember putting up
the very first pole.
That's been 24 years ago.
That first erection to start
the process to figure out
where to put the
deck and the frame.
We're gonna stand the first
pole up here so we can build
a cabin on posts.
You think that hole's big
enough for that post to fit in?
CODY: It'll slip right in.
COLBERT: Cody go measure
the pole like this and
see if it's
this wide or wider.
See if it's big enough
to fit down in the hole.
What about the other way?
CODY: Nope.
COLBERT: So what we have
to do is we have to make
the hole a little bit wider.
How do you like our rulers?
To me this is a
really big deal.
I'm rebuilding my home a
home I'm going to share with
my family with my grandkids
so as they get older they'll
not only have Grandpa's
cabin to go to but they'll
remember how they
helped put it together.
NARRATOR: Colbert's fire
damaged tools throw a wrench
in his plans and Tony goes
to great lengths for love.
TONY: There's still like
some smushy bits on this thing.
[gagging]
GABRIEL: It's not the best
time to be fishing in the
kelp bed but I gotta
catch a couple fish.
NARRATOR: Off the coast
of California Gabriel is
battling the unforgiving
ocean currents in hopes of
catching a fish.
GABRIEL: There's a
big riptide...Ohh!
It's crazy out here.
This is like 35-40
knot gale force winds...
which doesn't
happen very often.
I think I gotta go in.
No fish today.
It was almost impossible
just to get the hook to go
down to the bottom because
of all the current and chop.
It didn't go too well but
maybe tomorrow when it calms
down a little bit in the
morning I'll have better luck.
NARRATOR: With no luck
on the ocean Gabriel has
no choice but to
eat his own bait.
GABRIEL: I think my best bet
is to take the mussels that
I got for fishing and
cook a few of those up.
You wanna cook 'em
until they pop open.
Now these mussels are one of
my favorite things to eat.
But mussels collect toxins
in the water that can make
you really sick
and also kill you.
With mussels you can test it
by touching your tongue to
the mussel and if you get
like a numbness in your
mouth then you know
there's toxins in there.
There's a little tiny bit
of a kind of twinge but I'm
kind of testing my
fate 'cause I'm pretty
hungry right now.
So good...alright.
NARRATOR: Hoping that he
hasn't eaten toxic mussels
Gabriel calls it a night.
GABRIEL: I'm gonna head over
to my little nest and get up
with the sun early in
the morning and see if the
wind's dead so I can try
another day and see if I can
catch some fish.
TONY: We gonna get
some vegetables?
AMELIA: Yes.
NARRATOR: Back in
North Carolina...
homesteaders Tony and
Amelia are planning a
celebration to mark the
three-year anniversary of their
life together on the land.
TONY: Should we
get some sochan?
AMELIA: Why not?
TONY: Let's get some sochan.
AMELIA: I wanna
get everything.
I wanna have like
a nice big feast.
NARRATOR: But with the
abundance of plant life growing
on their hillside
deciding what to eat is
going to be tough.
AMELIA: Hey look!
There's a bunch of
oyster mushrooms!
TONY: Cool.
Everything here is
here for a reason.
Above and below ground
there's more going on than
you can even conceive here
than you can even understand.
AMELIA: I think this is
the biggest wild strawberry
patch we have right here.
TONY: We're creating
this web of symbiotic
relationships with plants
and animals and fungi and
water and soil and sun
that take care of us and
meet our needs.
AMELIA: The dandelion
greens came up.
TONY: It's crazy to think
about how much people spend
on greens and herbs
in the grocery store.
Stuff like
almost grows wild.
NARRATOR: 20% of fresh
fruits and vegetables in
today's modern supermarket
spoil and get thrown away.
This forces grocery stores
to charge a 75% markup or
more to offset the loss.
TONY: I just got
a grasshopper.
They're starting to get
big this time of year.
Well I just think that
communities should just take
it upon themselves
to be resilient.
Instead some of the folks
have to drive off to the
city to like make money to
pay their mortgage to buy
pop tarts at the store
to make themselves sick.
It just it's not
making any sense.
You know let's
get some honey.
Real things like soil and
water and community that's
the way that we build in
resilience to our lives.
Not by having a stack of
cash that has nothing to
back it that you can
set on fire then you don't
have it anymore.
You know.
AMELIA: Ooh...look at
all those milk weeds.
TONY: But if you have
skills and materials then
you're good...you're safe.
You're safer than
a lot of people.
AMELIA: Let's see if there's
any wild strawberries down here.
TONY: Oh hell yeah...
I wanna have that.
COLBERT: What you do right
here when you're not getting
any dirt is you have
to poke like this and
break some dirt loose.
NARRATOR: In Georgia
Colbert's grandchildren are
helping him
rebuild his cabin.
COLBERT: Who's having fun?
Whoopee!
We're gonna start the
process move one of the
bigger logs and show them
the technique and then we'll
start lifting the pole.
It's gonna be hard to set
in the ground but we're all
gonna participate in the
process of starting the
building project.
NARRATOR: The first step is
to place utility poles deep
in the ground to
provide a solid foundation.
COLBERT: Now who wants
to pick up the post and
throw it in a hole.
Can you pick it up
and throw it in there?
Why not?
GRANDKID: It's too heavy.
CODY: Because he's weak.
COLBERT: Let me
show you a trick.
So what we're gonna do is
we're gonna hook this on here.
So you slip it down
here till it's tight.
NARRATOR: Colbert uses
a rope and pulley system
to create a
mechanical advantage.
COLBERT: If you push it
down like that then it slips.
But if you lift the
rope up then it locks.
NARRATOR: The system
requires less force by
transferring the weight of
the pole to the pulley and
rope making it
easier to move.
COLBERT: Now be careful
and see if you can get that
log to jump up
and go that way.
Look at that.
I think Chase is
stronger than Cody.
CODY: No.
COLBERT: As we lift this up
there's gonna be a lot of
pressure on the bottom end
the whole weight of the pole.
The problem with this is
that it went through the
fire and it's really
rusty and it might not work.
NARRATOR: To start building
the new foundation for his
cabin Colbert and his
grandchildren will need to
hoist this 400-pound utility
pole to a 90-degree angle
and anchor it in place.
COLBERT: If we start to
stand that up what could
possibly go wrong?
CODY: It could kill someone.
COLBERT: If that falls
where do you wanna be?
CODY: Out of the way.
COLBERT: Out of the way.
Does everybody
understand their job?
Everybody ready?
A little more Devon...
Oh (bleep).
COLBERT: Is everybody ready?
NARRATOR: In the Georgia
swamp frontiersman Colbert
and his grandchildren
are attempting to stand a
400-pound utility
pole in the ground for
the cabin's foundation.
DEVON: I bottomed out.
COLBERT: I see the problem.
Since he can't travel
anymore we have to figure
out something else to do.
Give yourself some slack and
move the slippery rope farther
to the end of the pole.
If we don't slip the anchor
point up higher on the pole
it'll make a great deal of
effort and stress but at the
last point we might have to
push it up with our hands.
I want you guys to start
pulling and help me lift it.
You guys ready?
GRANDKIDS: Yeah.
COLBERT: 1...2...3.
Ayyyy the pole's in!
We did the impossible with
simple tools and we did it
as a family.
CODY: That's pretty awesome.
COLBERT: Pretty awesome.
COLBERT: This may
not look like a lot.
Just a big utility pole.
But to me it's the
beginning start of my home.
The most important step
in any long journey is the
first step and I've
got the first step done.
There you go.
That's straight up and down.
NARRATOR: With the
hard work behind them it's
time for a meal.
But miles from civilization
they'll have to improvise to
put food on the table.
COLBERT: Instead of taking
the grandkids out for a
drive thru window meal that
they'll forget right away...
we're gonna catch an
organic...fresh fish.
Who wants a
tall fishing pole?
They'll remember that and
their tummies will remember.
Are you guys hungry?
GRANDKIDS: Yeah!
COLBERT: You feel
something Chelsea?
CHELSEA: I think so yeah...
I felt something.
COLBERT: Give it a
short yank...beautiful!
That's a nice small catfish.
These here are sharp
as needles and they have
barbs on them.
If they do stab you it'll
really burn a little bit.
Just put your mouth on it
and suck really hard and
suck the poison out
and spit and then you
should be alright.
Whew!
It sure is great having
grandkids and having a place
where they can play kind of
like their own private park
where they can come
to swim and fish.
DEVON: Got
another one Grandpa.
COLBERT: I'm really
proud of you guys.
This is awesome.
NARRATOR: While Colbert and
his grandkids reel in dinner...
back in the Blue
Ridge Mountains...
Thorn's daughter has
taken a turn for the worse.
THORN: Hey.
[Briar coughing].
How are you doing?
You want some medicine?
BRIAR: Yeah.
THORN: We're just
about out of this.
[Briar coughing].
Right now Briar has a
pretty serious cough.
If it dropped into her
chest and really got into
her lungs it might
be a doctor visit.
So I'm treating her
with Usnea tincture...
is a moss that's antiviral.
I gotta make
some more sweetie.
But I'm running a
little low on medicine.
So we really need to get
out in the back country and
bring some plants
home that we can make
some medicine with.
NARRATOR: Thorn will
take his goat with him to
train her in the
art of goat packing.
THORN: I'm going with a
super light rawhide bags
that I'm making.
My goat hasn't ever packed
before so it's gonna be
exciting I'm sure.
[Briar coughing].
I'm here sweetie.
Whoa...whoa...whoa.
This place where I'm
in is disturbed land.
About 75 years
ago it was pasture.
That's different from
where I'm headed...
which is an
old growth forest.
It's a vastly different
landscape and a lot of it is
the elevation climb.
NARRATOR: Thorn plans to
travel to the backcountry to
an old growth forest where
a wide array of medicinal
plants are
known to be found.
The trek will span thousands
of feet of elevation over
multiple mountain ridges.
THORN: I'm not gonna
be able to take Briar.
It's too much of a hike.
Let's head out.
So I'm gonna drop her off
at some friends' place just
right over the ridge and I
can just continue on my way.
C'mon goat.
NARRATOR: Gabriel braves
the waves to hook a meal.
GABRIEL: Got a little bite.
C'mon!
[Briar coughing].
NARRATOR: In the
Blue Ridge Mountains of
North Carolina...Thorn
needs to get medicine for his
daughter Briar before
her cough gets worse.
THORN: I'm gonna head out and
go a little bit of back country
and see if I can find
some medicine for you sweetie.
I'm not gonna be
able to take Briar.
It's too much of a hike.
So I'm gonna drop her off
at some friend's place just
right over the ridge and I
can just continue on my way.
Hey.
TONY: Hey dudes.
AMELIA: Hi...how are you?
THORN: We're alright.
TONY: Thorn is a friend of
ours that I first met right
on the other side of that
ridge and now he lives right
on the other
side of that ridge.
AMELIA:
Hi...good to see you.
Thorn's a great friend.
TONY: We all have an
affinity for living life
and being free.
AMELIA: So where are
you headed to today?
THORN: I'm actually heading
out into the back country
and I'm trying to get
some medicine for her.
She's got a bit of a cough.
[Briar coughing].
AMELIA: Yeah?
THORN: So...is it cool if
she could maybe hang out here?
AMELIA: Of course!
THORN: If I thought that
Briar's cough wouldn't
respond to herbs I
would take her to the doctor
in a heartbeat.
But I do think that the
medicine I'm gonna find is
gonna help a lot.
AMELIA: Be
careful out there.
THORN: Yeah...see you soon.
BRIAR: Bye.
NARRATOR: There's still
plenty to do to get ready for
their anniversary dinner
so Amelia enlists Briar's
help selecting
ingredients from their garden.
BRIAR: Hey look!
AMELIA: Oh these
are the autumn olives.
BRIAR: They're ripe!
AMELIA: I don't
think they're ripe yet.
BRIAR: No taste them!
AMELIA: Really?
BRIAR: Yes taste them!
AMELIA: Here's one.
Oh hey...you're
right; they are ripe!
BRIAR: Mm-hm!
[Briar coughing].
NARRATOR: While Amelia
and Briar continue to pick
herbs and vegetables...
Tony is working on an
unusual anniversary present.
TONY: It's stinky.
It's Amelia and I's
three-year anniversary of
living on the land together
and for our anniversary I'm
gonna make Amelia a
pig's tooth necklace.
Look at that.
Oh gross...maggots
on a pig tooth.
I'm a little nervous
that I'm going to vomit.
There's still some like
smushy bits on this thing.
Yeee-a...God those
are gnarly teeth.
This is my first time
doing pig dentistry.
I want all of the teeth...
not just a couple.
I want all of them.
Ah-ha...This is
strangely satisfying;
smashing these rotten bones
apart and pulling teeth out.
It's getting less gross the
longer I'm going on here.
Ohhhhh what?!
It's the bullet.
That is so crazy.
That's what killed this pig.
NARRATOR: This pig's head
has been rotting for the
last three weeks so a
little cleaning is in order.
TONY: If you look up
love in the encyclopedia
you'll see a picture of
me brushing pig's teeth.
That's how much
I love my wife.
NARRATOR: As Tony polishes
those pearly whites...
in California Gabriel is
determined to catch a fish
for his homecoming.
GABRIEL: There's so
much current right now...
this is a big
upwelling for the ocean.
This is kind of like the
last big winds of the spring.
There's too many
waves in here and I don't
wanna lose my pack.
So I think I'm gonna head
out over on this side away
from the rocks.
If I paddle really fast I'll
probably make it before I
get hit by too many waves.
I'm gonna try that.
NARRATOR: Springtime swells
make setting a lure near
shore almost impossible.
So for his next attempt
Gabriel is swimming out past
the breakers into a deep
and more dangerous area.
GABRIEL: It is gonna be a
challenge to get fish out
here with the wind as it is
but I'm gonna try my luck.
NARRATOR: Gabriel is
dropping a lure of mussel
into the dense kelp
bed hoping for a bite.
GABRIEL: Come on!
I got a little bite...
Yeah!
It'll be a nice
fish for Luna!
You never can predict
what the ocean is gonna do.
You just have to move
with it and that's part of
the dance of the ocean.
Awesome day.
THORN: C'mon goat.
NARRATOR: Back in the
Blue Ridge primitive woodsman
Thorn is searching for
a medicinal mushroom for
his sick daughter.
THORN: This is deep forest.
We get up into the
hemlocks that's old growth.
NARRATOR: Old growth
forests generally contain trees
that are at
least 120 years old.
THORN: I'm just out
looking for reishi mushroom.
I think they're gonna
be super crucial for Briar
and her sickness.
This is one of the
only places that I know
where they grow.
NARRATOR: Reishi
mushrooms have been used
medicinally for
over 4,000 years.
Recent studies have shown
that the mushrooms can boost
the immune system and
have a healing effect.
THORN: The reishi mushroom
grows on hemlock trees
that have been downed.
So I'm looking for big
trunks on the ground.
Starting to get
into some hemlock.
The whole reason I'm
here is these old hemlocks.
NARRATOR: Because reishi
mushrooms grow on fallen
mature hemlock trees
Thorn will have to travel
deeper into the
forest to find them.
THORN: I'm coming
up on the falls.
It's making me thirsty.
It's kind of making
me need to pee too.
Everything about this
place is beautiful.
I think the main feeling that
I have right now is gratitude
for the opportunity
to do things like this.
I've got a new camp
where I have a lot of
land to explore.
I really feel like I'm
putting my roots down and
getting the
nourishment from the forest.
Just like these trees.
It gets pretty
steep up here.
NARRATOR: As he moves
hundreds of feet higher
Thorn leaves his
goat behind to travel as
light as possible.
THORN: I kind of want to be
able to move kind of freely
just in case I have to
kind of clamber over some
logs or whatever.
This is a slippery slope.
The scary thing is
not finding any reishi.
Nothing.
Gotta help Briar
get over this cough.
NARRATOR: Thorn
goes in for the kill.
THORN: I think I see a
squirrel right here.
TONY: Rummaging
through my junk here.
Seeing what I can find.
NARRATOR: In
North Carolina...
homesteader Tony is
working on a unique gift for
his wife Amelia.
TONY: For our anniversary
I'm gonna make Amelia a
pig's tooth necklace.
I know I've got
something somewhere I just
gotta find it right?
I'm trying to find something
to string the teeth together.
Oh!
Copper wire.
I think I can strip this and
make a string to hold the
necklace together.
Now people are a lot more
apt to just throw stuff away
and say "Oh that's junk"
and send it to the landfill.
But we understand
the value of junk.
I'm drilling holes into the
pig's teeth and stringing
them on to the copper wire.
I don't know if most dudes
would do this for their lady
because they'd probably go
out and buy some stupid ring
at the store you know?
Is this starting to
look like something?
I think that Amelia
will like the way that the
necklace looks but I think
even more so Amelia's gonna
like the fact that I was
fidgeting with a rotten
pig's head for her
'cause that's a pretty
big deal for me.
NARRATOR: As Tony
puts the finishing touches
on his gift...
back in the swamps of
south Georgia Colbert's two
daughters are visiting
to see the progress their
children have made
with their grandfather.
COLBERT: We've already
erected the first pole for the
corner post for the
cabin and all the kids helped.
Pretty neat huh?
DAUGHTER: He did it once and
he'll be able to do it again
I know he will it'll
just take him some time.
But he'll get it...
he'll do it and it's gonna
be great when he completes it.
COLBERT: Is anybody hungry?
ALL: Yeah.
COLBERT: Alright.
You guys did a great job
catching fish and I'm gonna
show you how to cook 'em
without any equipment.
I want them to see how
important it is and take
responsibility for
taking a life...
to use it wisely
and consume it.
So what I do is
open up the gills...
is their breathing apparatus
put my thumb in there and
I twist and that pops the
skin and twist and pop and
twist their head off.
DAUGHTER: I can't do that.
COLBERT: It's just part of
the process of killing the
fish so you can eat it.
What I think is really
gross and weird is that you
read a package and it says
"mechanically
separated chicken."
What does that mean?
Does that mean someone ran
over it with a lawn mower?
You take your thumb and pop
their intestines out and rip
like this and rip 'em
right down to their vent.
It's incredibly awesome
and exciting to watch your
grandkids from little
bitty kids teach them
all kinds of stuff...
everything...watch them
grow up and get bigger
and bigger and bigger.
Rip it apart...Rip.
CODY: In the face...ugh!
COLBERT: So what we
really want to accomplish.
Let me check this one.
Yep it's so soft
it's coming apart.
Well what I always say is
you need food and water and
shelter and family.
Mm...now that's fresh fish!
CHELSEA: It's
actually really good.
COLBERT: I've got food and
water and as a family we're
rebuilding the shelter.
What are we doing?
DAUGHTER: You're gonna
stand in between them.
COLBERT: That's a pretty
heartwarming experience.
DAUGHTER 2:
Ah...that's a good face Dad.
NARRATOR: While Colbert's
family heads back to town
back in the Blue Ridge
Mountains primitive woodsman
Thorn is on a goat-packing
trip to get medicinal
mushrooms for
his sick daughter.
THORN: I'm not finding
any reishi...nothing.
I think I see a
squirrel right here.
Fresh squirrel is awesome.
You can get 'em off the road
but it's nice to get one
with the bow.
That's one in the bag.
NARRATOR: While squirrel
will make a nice gift
for Tony and Amelia...
Thorn has yet to find
what he needs most...
medicine for his daughter.
THORN: My little girl
Briar is just so sick.
She's got this
lingering illness.
I've got to get some kind
of strong medicine for her.
It looks like a
pretty good sized one.
It's too old.
Not exactly what
I'm looking for.
I see one down a
little further.
Just gotta get to it
without wiping out.
Whoa...it's very slick.
Wow this one looks good.
I got it.
I found some
reishi and uh...
take this home and
make some tea for Briar.
Get her on her way
to feeling better.
C'mon...Good job.
THORN: Hey y'all.
AMELIA: Hey...you're back!
THORN: Made it.
NARRATOR: In
North Carolina...
Thorn has returned from a
long hike into the mountains
with a gift for
Tony and Amelia.
AMELIA: You got a squirrel!
THORN: Got a squirrel...
some meat.
AMELIA: Nice.
THORN: Got some
medicine for Briar.
Did you have fun
with Tony and Amelia?
BRIAR: I want to stay
here for a little while.
THORN: You want to stay
here a little bit longer?
AMELIA: We'll
borrow you any time.
THORN: Well... y'all are
welcome to that squirrel.
AMELIA: Thank you!
THORN: Thanks so much.
We'll see you
around for sure.
Bye.
TONY: Amelia and I have
lived here together for
three years now in
the forest garden.
We're gonna celebrate our
anniversary by eating a
bunch of delicious food
from the forest garden.
AMELIA: Gotta include
some meat with our feast.
So squirrel's the
perfect thing to add to our
vegetables and
eggs and berries.
Oh flowers...wow.
TONY: So I made
you something.
AMELIA: You
made me something?
TONY: Mhm...I sure did
and it's not a swale...
it's not a house.
It's an abstract
representation of awesome.
AMELIA: Wow...oh my
gosh it's beautiful!
It's my first piece
of jewelry from you.
TONY: This is the first piece
of jewelry I've ever made.
AMELIA: Was it hard
to pull them out?
TONY: Yeah and it
was pretty gross.
Smelled bad...
smelled like rotten pig.
AMELIA: Oh my God.
TONY: But I went
ahead and did it.
AMELIA: I'm impressed.
I can't believe
you did this.
TONY: Yeah...I can't
believe I made it either.
It's just mildly stinky.
AMELIA: That'll go away.
COLBERT: What I've learned
from the loss of my cabin is
letting go of an intense
emotional attachment to
something I've
made that I built.
And in that sense I
feel wealthy...because
all of nature...
if I need it...
is available for my
simple...physical needs.
♪ ♪
[Gabriel makes bird call].
LUNA: Hey...oh my gosh...
you're back!
GABRIEL: Hey!
[greeting each
other inaudibly].
Not many women would
support somebody to run off
for three months and trust
that I'm 100% there for her
and that's the reason that
I'm ready to marry her and
take it to the next step.
I paddled out and
fished a little bit.
I actually brought one back.
LUNA: Mmm...awesome.
♪ ♪
THORN: This'll
help your cough.
Just drop 'em right in.
They won't hurt you.
Life's looking pretty good
out here and I think heading
into this next fall
and this next winter...
Here you go.
I've got a lot of
knowledge that I've acquired
from just trying.
It's a good feeling to
feel at home in the woods.
♪ ♪
AMELIA: We've gotten
really far and I mean...
there's still a long way to
go but jeez...we have come a
really long way
this past year.
So maybe next year
we'll be having our spring
anniversary with a third
little human here with us.
TONY: The only babies I
want around here are ones
that I can eat.
AMELIA: Happy three-year
forest garden anniversary.
LUNA: Cheers.
GABRIEL: Yeah!
COLBERT: This is
my lookout spot.
I used to come up
here when I was younger.
Now I need a
ladder to get up here.
I come out and climb
it once in a while.
A lot of people ask me
how old I am and I say well
I'm just a teenager.
I'm kind of an
antique teenager but I'm
just a teenager.
I've been a
teenager for fifty years.
[laughs].
♪ ♪
GABRIEL: This has been
an awesome experience.
I'm really grateful for
the time out on the land.
I put my whole soul and
energy into it and I've
gotten a lot out of it.
♪ ♪
THORN: There has been
some tough times out here.
But that's okay.
There's
struggles everywhere.
TONY: Amelia and I were
born into a culture of making
money and then taking it
to buy your things and we
dropped out of that culture.
So now we're trying to pull
together fragments that make
sense and glue them together
and make what I think is a
better life for ourselves.
COLBERT: Everything in
nature has found a niche...
a perfect harmony...
a balance.
Man needs to find his niche
his perfect balance where he
fits in the natural cycles.
You gotta find yourself.
I feel like a little kid
in the Garden of Eden.
Just playing in the woods.